round nine point five six four or nine
and five hundred sixty four thousandths
to the nearest tenth to the nearest
tenth so let me write it a little bit
larger nine point five six four and we
need a round to the nearest tenth so
what's the tenths place the tenths place
is right here this right here represents
five tenths this is the ones place this
is the tenths place this is the
hundredths place and this is the
thousands place right here so we need to
round to the nearest tenth so if we
round up this will be nine point six if
we round down this will be nine point
five and just like regular rounding when
we're not dealing with decimals you move
to one spot or you look at one place to
the right or one place lower I guess and
you say is that five or larger if it is
you round up if it isn't your round down
six is definitely five or larger so we
want to round up we want to round up so
this nine point five six four becomes
9.6 9.6 or we could call this nine and
six tenths and then we're done